oh those come and sneak up on you
don't chill
[Music]
hey tasty it's me danny drejo and as you
can probably guess one of my favorite
things to do is to cook tacos today i'm
going to show you three of my favorite
recipes first up is a quick and
delicious 10-minute shrimp taco next is
a savory one-hour fried chicken taco and
if you really want to impress i'm going
to show you a brisket taco that takes a
full day to make now let's get cooking
okay first up is our shrimp diablo taco
now the machete is not needed for this
recipe start with our roasted garlic
chipotle sauce our olive oil garlic
powder
salt
honey
like the way i did that it was cool and
then our lemon juice
all these go into the blender to make
our diablo sauce
you know i used a blender in a movie
before you make people tell you
something
mix it well now we've got a bowl of
shrimp mixed very very well with our
diablo sauce this is a quick marinade
and then we're going to grill it we got
our pan nice and hot now an old trick
that i learned was putting oil on one
side and just doing this that way it's
evenly spread
oh yeah two to three minutes flip it
over and the nice thing about shrimp is
that it cooks fast and
it's absolutely delicious especially
with the diamond sauce that's the kicker
okay now these start to look nice good
and crispy
smell absolutely delicious
sir may i have another
okay now we're almost done with the rim
diablo get our tortillas that you've put
in the oven
wrapped in tin foil for about five
minutes what i always like to do is put
the guacamole first so that it'll spread
on the tortilla and then cabbage and
pickled onion this is what we're mixing
up right now next our piece de resistant
shrimp never skimp on the shrimp now
it's little cilantro some people don't
like cilantro then
of course
our lime juice
delicious for a 10 minute taco this
can't be beat and kids don't talk with
your mouth full
up next is our fried chicken taco now
that's a winner first step is our flour
pour our flour in here next garlic
powder onion powder oregano paprika
little bit of cayenne of course some
salt and black pepper then what we're
doing is using chicken thighs and
mix a little bit with the buttermilk
chicken's looking good and we're ready
to move on to our next step once it gets
to 350 we're ready to go from the
buttermilk
to the flour make sure you mix it real
good and then shake it off
and then just oh
it's been about seven minutes and our
chicken is looking good you're looking
for a real nice golden brown
crispy cover
okay now we're going to make our
chocolate crema sour cream
next is our chipotle peppers with adobe
sauce
salt or lime juice it's my favorite part
offering heavy machinery
we're gonna put about a quarter cup
into our cabbage
salt and pepper
and a little bit of olive oil mix this
up oh yeah and really this is good just
like this pico de gallo is one of my
favorite sauces our pico de gallo we've
got chips jalapeno red onions and then
the tomato
cilantro
or lemon juice a little salt
some olive oil we wanted to do a healthy
taco with a little bit of protein so
what we did was get lettuce cabbage and
then we got our pico de gallo
let's do a little more
sauce and here is your perfect one-hour
fried chicken taco
next is the barbecue brisket taco now
this was inspired by my mom's recipe for
varva koa so the first step salt next
sugar next is cumin pepper
and garlic now what we do is this we're
putting this all over this brisket okay
set this in plastic let it sit for
approximately eight hours
that's right you heard it eight hours
now
believe me this one's really worth it
now the key to this recipe is the three
b's
brine
brownie and braids right now we are
going to brown get your oil there it is
[Music]
oh yeah
sizzle sizzle sizzle mom you're watching
all right now i'm turning this over
right now that's browning
you don't want to get it any more than
that do the other side
this is real good and brown so here we
go put this over here
now we get to our sauce first naturally
our onion
garlic coriander cumin chili powder we
get our vinegar bay leaves and tomatoes
and these
we crush up with our hand looking good
next we got our chapoli this takes a
little while sometimes it is our
molasses
last but not least is a cup and a half
of water now this is packed with flavor
we're gonna put our brisket in here
soaking up all them juices we're gonna
cover this and then bring this to a boil
okay now this is pretty
well at a boil so now what we'll do is
get this
cover it
and put the lid back on put the oven at
350 cook it for eight hours we just
brought this out of the oven pulled the
brisket out we reduced the broth by half
now at trails we don't even touch the
brisket until we can pull it apart with
just two forks like that oh yeah
here we go oh now
hey the brisket came out great
like always
remember first go the tortillas and then
go with our brisket for this smells
delicious already a little bit of pico
de gallo we've got our tortilla cheese
and don't forget the tortilla strips
there's no words to describe what's
going on in my mouth right now
all right there you have it three tacos
you've got shrimp diablo you've got
fried chicken and you've got the
barracuda brisket if you have trouble
it's all in the cookbook all of it hey
thank you for watching
get cooking or
i hope to see you at the restaurants
you